this high septon maynard he recorded
everything even recorded his own bowel
movements
what does annulment mean it's when a man
sets aside his lawful wife Maynard says
here that he issued an annulment for
Prince Rhaegar and remarried him to
someone else at the same time in a
secret ceremony in Dorne Mad King is
dead
Rhaegar lies beneath the ground why
weren't you there to protect your prince
our Prince wanted us here
hey youtubers it's Charlie so a lot of
you requested a bonus video for gillies
big info bomb revealing Rhaegar
Targaryen got married to lyanna stark's
secretly after putting aside his lawful
wife Elia Martell so this is gonna be a
clarification on the timeline and sort
of an examination of the reasoning
behind the events of Robert's rebellion
in why common sense didn't prevail and
they didn't just tell everyone what they
were doing I'm going to set aside my
wife and get married to this
fifteen-year-old girl from the north
that's betrothed to Robert Baratheon so
like a lot of big Wars that get started
over contentious things everybody's
asking the question how come this
spiraled out of control why did
everybody do the thing they did
why didn't lyanna stark's send a raven
to Winterfell explaining that she was
running away with Rhaegar because if you
don't remember why Robert's rebellion
started it's not because of her
abduction that's not the thing that
started it it was actually her abduction
that prompted Rickard stark and Brandon
to go to King's Landing to petition the
Mad King to do something about the
situation he promptly burned them in
Robert used that as an excuse to start
the rebellion with Jon Arryn Jon Arryn
was sort of the first big person to call
his bannermen in the Vale Gould town
here was where the first official battle
took place and then I'll sort of chart
the timeline as they go around but
that's not quite as important as what
Rhaegar and Lyanna are doing because
there was all this other stuff going on
in the background we can tip the hat to
Littlefinger for revealing to Sansa
during season 5 that Rhaegar was truly
in love with Lyanna stark regardless of
the fact that he was married to Elia
Martell at the time and it wasn't so
much as book readers early believe that
Rhaegar was just this crazy person
totally obsessed and took her believing
that a child with her would be the
fulfillment of the prophecy based on the
information the show has given us it's
implied that he was obsessed with the
prophecy and also in love with her it
was a two birds one stone situation that
spiraled out of control
because of what the Mad King did so if
you want to blame somebody for Robert's
rebellion blame the Mad King killing
Rickard stark and Brandon because had he
not killed Brandon and Rickard you
probably just would have wound up with a
small group of Kingsguard in conjunction
with some of Ned Stark's men right
around the kingdom looking for the two
of them the most fascinating thing the
biggest WTF the people point to during
all this is the idea that Robert's
rebellion lasted for a little over a
year and it seems like at no point
during that period did either Liana or
Rhaegar try to let anybody know what was
going on just the two of them with
presumably a maester to watch over Liana
while she was pregnant in Arthur Danes
Kingsguard at the tower just sort of
waiting it out waiting for Jon Snow to
be born and then who knows what they
would have done after that maybe they
would have emerged and tried to explain
to everyone but you rewind to the
tourney at Harrenhal so this is sort of
the timeline of events and you get an
idea for the reasoning of why Rhaegar
did what he did and why Liana probably
did what she did as well because she's
just as culpable as he is in all this so
around the Year 280 Prince Rhaegar and
Lord Walder went conspired to throw the
tourney at Harrenhal it's intended to be
the most lavish big tournament event
that the kingdom has ever seen bigger
even than the tournament that Tywin
Lannister threw a couple years earlier
to celebrate the birth of Daenerys
brother Viserys so you might remember
that from the season 5 opener where
Cersei is going to see Maggie the Frog
that was happening while Tywin's
Lannister celebrating Viserys was
happening so the tourney at Harrenhal
was a couple years after that and the
idea is is that Rhaegar was going to use
this tournament and make it such a big
thing in order to convince all of the
Lords of the kingdom to come because
just because a tournament happens
doesn't mean that everybody in the
kingdom turns up but you make the prizes
for the tournament big enough people
will turn up for a chance to win some
money
Rhaegar as Crown Prince was basically
the richest person in the kingdom after
Tywin Lannister who had just stood on
his tournament so the idea is as the Mad
King is genuinely mad by this point
Rhaegar wants to depose him while at the
same time being obsessed with the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
so the only way to get rid of the Mad
King is open rebellion where a bunch of
people die or you call it grey Council
the Lords of the realm collectively
agreed to depose the Mad King in place
someone more sane Rhaegar on the throne
in his place so Rhaegar is obsessed with
the war for the dawn he's only worried
about the night
in the White Walkers coming back so he
knows that the realm needs to unite
meaning they need to have a same king on
the throne so this is where the tourney
at Harrenhal comes in but Lord Varys
master of whispers to the Mad King gets
wind of this and suggests to the Mad
King that Rhaegar is using the
tournament to plot against him and he
should go to the tournament himself so
the Mad King turns up Rhaegar is unable
to throw his Great Council and conspire
with the other Lords but while he's
there he wins the tournament
in front of all the Lords of the kingdom
rides past his wife crowns Lyanna stark
with the blue roses and causes this huge
scandal but then shortly thereafter he
supposedly abducted her like they ran
off together so you have to imagine that
they were either falling in love and
that is just culminated at the tourney
at Harrenhal or just something really
intense happened he charmed her and she
was like okay I'll run away with you
handsome prince man let's go so giving
them the benefit of the doubt you can
assume that Rhaegar probably met her
some time in the past and fancied her a
little bit but while this was happening
the tourney of Harrenhal she's 14 years
old she's about the age Daenerys is when
she was married to Khal Drogo Daenerys
was 13 she was a little bit younger in
Rhaegar is 22 you can be creeped out by
that if you want but Khal Drogo was much
older than Daenerys when they got
married so if you don't think that Khal
Drogo and Daenerys is creepy then you're
not allowed to think that Rhaegar and
Lyanna is creepy this all happens during
the course of year 281
so then shortly thereafter they run away
together to Dorne / Septon maynard's
crap diaries that Gilly found he knows
his marriage to Elia Martell and marries
Leon a stark so a lot of people have
pointed out that Rhaegar really sucks
because he set aside very nice person
Elia Martell who was always nice to him
even though their marriage was a
political one they weren't in love with
each other he had two children with her
but because the prophecy of the prince
who was promised talks about the three
heads of the Dragon Elia Martell was not
able to have children after their second
child so Rhaegar needed that third child
and he was also in love with Lyanna
stark so remember two birds one stone
the night Kings coming we need the three
heads of the Dragon so King Henry the
eighth style he petitions the church
to give him that annulment presumably
the maesters or whoever it was Andorran
said okay crown prince will give you
your annulment even though technically
the faith of the seven doesn't allow for
annulment in around the time they're
getting married
Rickard in Brandon go to King's Landing
to petition the Mad King to go find
Rhaegar bring him back because they're
under the impression that leotta Stark
was kidnapped by Rhaegar and not in love
with them they didn't know anything
about their relationship so here's where
we start to get to crazytown like how
come someone just didn't tell them that
she was in love with them so year to 82
they go to King's Landing get bird
shortly thereafter Robert's rebellion
begins then within a year of that Lyanna
stark dies giving birth to Jon Snow
right after the sack of King's Landing
so it sounds like would probably ended
up happening in probably the reason why
initially after running away and getting
married they didn't tell everyone is
because Robert's rebellion had already
started and people were dying left and
right and they were worried about what
would happen they would either kill the
baby too they might have tried to kill
Rhaegar and he believed himself the only
hope for the kingdom because the Mad
King needed to be put aside and he also
probably didn't want to leave his child
the prince who was promised without a
father to guide him in the war for the
dawn so it's sort of like that Romeo and
Juliet thing where they run off the
kingdom goes to war over it and they're
like oh [ __ ] we didn't really mean to
start this so maybe we lay low for a
while while this baby is being born and
then try to find a way out of this but
before that could happen
Rhaegar is called back to the Trident
he's killed by Robert he then the rest
is history they sack King's Landing
right after the Battle of the Trident
then Ned Stark comes down here you get
this scene where's my sister
and before Septon Maynard here reveals
that Rhaegar and Lyanna got married
before Jon Snow was born meaning he's
legitimate people had already gotten the
idea that the fact that the Kingsguard
were there to protect her and the baby
wasn't so much because the baby was
important but because the Kingsguard are
meant to protect the Crown Prince in
John Snow after Rhaegar was next in line
for the throne and it is important to
remember that as Crown Prince Jon Snow
has a better claim to the throne than
Daenerys even though nothing will
probably come of it on the TV show
they're really fuzzy about the rules of
succession on the TV show and most
people don't listen to them even george
RR martin left room for the rules to be
broken like Circe broke the rules when
she took the throne she had no claim to
it and John Snow is not petty so he's
not going to go to Daenerys and say I
have a right to the throne that's
greater than yours so it belongs to me
not to you he's not gonna do anything
like that but hopefully that clears some
of the reasoning up why Rhaegar and
Lyanna did what they did you have to
remember that she was 15 years old when
they got married
16 when John Snow was born so Sansa
right now on the TV show is older than
she was
she's like sonses age when she was
married to Ramsay Bolton
so rewind a couple seasons and think
about how characters that age on the
show act and it's not too outlandish to
believe that she would be impulsive
they say that Arya favors her in her
disposition and kind of the way she
looks she looks a little bit like lianna
but think about how Aria reacted when
Ned Stark told her what her destiny was
going to be you marry a great lord live
in a big castle and she's like that's
not me so that's kind of what Lyanna
stark was like when this was all going
on I'm gonna do what I want to do in
Rhaegar obsessed with the prophecy in
need of a new wife and a new heir just
took it all as a sign from the universe
this is the fulfillment of the prophecy
the path is clear go get married to her
set aside your wife who can't have any
more children
and then everything goes to [ __ ] after
that the wheel continues to turn so the
whole idea that Daenerys is trying to
break the wheel is the idea of people
not doing crazy stuff anymore and things
going off the rails which obviously
isn't gonna happen this season season 8
is going to happen we have the war for
the dawn so let me know in the comments
how many more Rhaegar flashbacks do you
think that we'll see on the TV show we
haven't seen any yet we've only seen
lianna start the show hasn't confirmed
their relationship so they have to do
that first then maybe you know I'm
really hoping that we get to see battle
with the Trident and see him die and
whisper lianas name maybe that's gonna
be a season 8 thing but what will happen
is is I'll post a new bonus video on
Sunday before episode 6 airs please
don't post spoilers in the comments I
know there was a leak this isn't a video
about episode 6 so we'll talk about
episode 6 when I post that video on
Sunday like I normally would
it's just gonna be like last time
similar situation there is a new round
of the HBO now giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video while you wait for
everything you can click here for my
episode 6 trailer video and you can
click here for my episode 5 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you